oh yeah you can go all your way
but i've been a republican all my life
were you a republican
all your life i was an independent
during the time of reagan bush
i'm not trying to return to reagan bush
my positions don't talk about things
that you suggest they talk about
the former governor of massachusetts who
became the republican nominee
just what nine years ago
was just booed off the stage in utah
where he is the republican senator my oh
my how things
can change take a listen to mitt
romney's chilly reaction
now you know me as a person who says
what he thinks and i don't hide the fact
that i wasn't a fan of our last
president's character issues
aren't you embarrassed
and i'm also no fan of the president's
yeah sure
my friends this is the moment i was
talking about
please thank you show respect
so yeah i understand that uh i have a
few folks that don't like me terribly
much and i
i'm sorry about that oh yeah you could
you can go all your way
but i've been a republican all my life
thank you
tough crowd met tough crowd and and mitt
always presents himself as he's the
adult in the room
he's mr republican i'm the old principal
kind of republican but now you guys have
gone crazy i've been a republican all my
life you
you johnny come latelies i've been a
republican all my life
is that so met let's rewind the tape to
when you were running for senator from
massachusetts
against ted kennedy in 1994. were you a
republican
all your life look i was an independent
during the time of reagan bush
i'm not trying to return to reagan bush
my positions don't talk about things
that you suggest they talk about
oh oh i guess you weren't a republican
all your life
i guess during the most important
republican administration in recent
memory before donald trump
and i guess in that there were two terms
defeated the cold war i guess it ends up
being a more consequential republican
administration
mitt romney was not a republican i was
an independent during the time of reagan
bush i'm not trying to return to reagan
bush now he may have been a republican
during that time and he may have just
been lying to ted kennedy but this is
the problem with mitt romney
i am not saying that i despise mitt
romney
i detest him my he's just
weak that's the problem there are many
things i admire about mitt romney
well that's not there's one his hair i
admire the hair i he's got great hair
but as a political matter romney wreck
represents the liberal wing of the
republican party just like his dad did
george romney and mitt romney has been
on the wrong side of a lot of issues
here he was on the wrong side of the
reagan administration for goodness sakes
he was on the wrong side of obamacare
he's on the wrong side of blm the guy
was out marching with blm last year
blm was torching the country coast to
coast
starting in minneapolis but not ending
in minneapolis and what does romney do
does he go out and say hey
don't burn down the country hey this is
bad we oppose this organization no he
goes and marches with them
so i think romney got exactly what he
deserves there
at the utah state convention hey there
do not
go anywhere if you've made it here this
far congratulations you have jumped over
all the obstacles that youtube
puts out for you to not see this content
but if you want to make it easier to get
the content
ring the bell like
subscribe make sure that you have the
best chance for big tech not to totally
shut you down
and screw up your ability to check out
all of these videos we'll see you next
[Music]
[Music]
time